si vous aimez le succès lever la main
si vous pensez qu oser être soi est une
des recettes pour réussir dans la vie
lever les deux mains avec moi peut-être
que comme moi et comme beaucoup de
personnes vous avez eu des frustrations
vous avez voulu réaliser des rêves être
vous même et vous n'avez pas osé à cause
de votre environnement de la société ou
alors de vous même peut-être que vous
avez en fouillant vous des possibilités
dédain des passions que vous n'avez pas
osé révéler au monde
[Musique]
imaginez qu'on vous donne les clés pour
réussir à découvrir votre moi imaginez
que vous sachiez comment devenir vous
même
bonjour
je m'appelle dabou fall et je vais
partager avec vous mon chemin et le
chemin pour oser être vous même
je vais commencer par ma petite histoire
la petite histoire c'est mon parcours
comment est ce que je suis devenu moi
même il y avait deux ans après avoir
fait des études d'ingénieur en
informatique avoir passé un troisième
cycle en gestion et en finance je me
retrouve à abidjan pour trouver du
travail comme tous ceux qui ont terminé
leurs études et quelqu'un vient me voir
et me dit écoute c'est une société qui
va commencer voilà l'organigramme je te
vois mieux dans tel département en
l'occurrence informatique et ou finance
moi je réfléchis je regarde je me dis
hou lala l'informatique j'adore c'était
bien pour les études mais je ne me
voyais pas dans un bureau enfermé en
train de programmer la finance bon la
comptabilité c'est pas très drôle et je
ne me sentais pas en accord avec cette
formation que j'avais fait que j'aimais
mais qui ne correspondait pas forcément
un qui j'étais alors cette société qui
aujourd'hui est partenaire de
l'événement je fais partie des premières
employées pour ne pas dire une la
première employée du commercial et du
marketing de cette société que je ne
m'aime pas mais merci à vous d'être là
c'était il ya 22 ans
il ya 22 ans j'ai donc dit est ce que je
ne peux pas être responsable marketing
me dit bon marketing mais cela ne
correspond pas à votre parcours
je dis est ce que vous pouvez me donner
la possibilité de faire mes preuves
donnez moi la chance de vous prouver que
je peux être cette personne parce que
aux fins de mois je sais que je suis
cette personne
d'accord
on va vous laisser faire donc je suis
devenu responsable marketing
la première m 15h01 de cette entreprise
n'avait pas d'employés avait pas de
bureau il n'y avait rien à l'époque et
j'ai fait mon chemin dans ce secteur
mais qu'est-ce qui m'a fallu pour y
arriver
qu'est-ce qui m'a fallu à comme je le
disais être soir la vie n'est pas de
recherche d'expérience mais de soi même
j'ai commencé d'abord premièrement temps
à me poser des questions parce que
pendant ce parcours professionnel après
avoir été responsable marketing
j'ai gravi les échelons j'ai travaillé
dans plusieurs sociétés dans le monde
entier dans plusieurs pays d'afrique
jusqu'à arriver à les postes de
direction en expatriation et tout au
long de cette carrière il y avait quand
même une petite voix en moins qui me
parlait est-ce que je ne suis que cette
directrice
cette professionnelle cette dame madame
la directrice du marketing et du
commercial
est-ce que je ne suis que ça où est ce
que je suis autre chose il avait un mois
une autre voie qui me parlait et cette
voie elle n'arrêtait pas de me hanter et
de me persécuter
j'ai fini par l'écouté est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai commencé par écrire il ya dix
ans j'ai commencé un blog qui s'appelle
naboo love
ce blog a été lu par des millions de
personnes dans le monde et ce bled main
et la boue la direction générale la
direction marketing commercial d'une
grande société de map à mener je me suis
posé des question qui suis-je
posez vous cette question qui à bout est
ce que vous savez il répondre simplement
peut-être que vous êtes docteur comme
docteur masson beaucoup coach comme
madame lydia ou directeurs d'entreprises
comme madame diallo qui est là mais
qu'est ce que cette personnalité
professionnel c'est ce que vous êtes
réellement ou est ce que c'est juste la
personnalité que vous réfléchissez vers
envers le monde
il ya en vous quelque chose de l'autre
n'est ce pas qu'elle soit une valeur par
rapport à ses valeurs
est ce que vous êtes en accord avec vos
valeurs dans votre vie quotidienne
est ce que vous savez déjà où vous
projeter dans cinq ans dans dix ans dans
15 ans est-ce que vous avez une vision
ferme de ce que vous voulez est-ce que
là où vous êtes maintenant parce que
nous allons voir où est ce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui maintenant est ce que
là je suis maintenant je me posais la
question en tant que directeur de
société et ensuite je suis devenu
entrepreneur donc j'ai osé créer
l'entreprise ça c'était une autre
facette de ma personnalité
j'étais entre employés pendant des
années plus d'une dizaine d'années dans
des sociétés avec de très bons salaires
mais j'ai passé le cap et j'ai osé
entreprendre dans un secteur qui me
plaisait parce que là où j'étais en tant
que chef d'entreprise qui réussissait
qui gagne et bien saviez en voyageant en
ayant des clients est ce que j'étais moi
même nom
je me suis rendu compte comme en
écrivant en partageant avec les gens je
me sentais de plus en plus moi même je
recevais de plus en plus de messages il
y avait de plus en plus de personnes qui
me contacter pour me parler de leurs
problèmes pour partager avec moi leur
histoire et qui me demandait mais
comment est ce que je fais pour être
bien dans ma peau comment est ce que je
fais pour être heureuse je ne suis pas
coach mais tout simplement j'étais moi
même je réfléchis non authenticité à
travers mes écrits je partager ce qu'ils
avaient réellement mes pensées mes
sensations
mes idées mes réflexions sur la vie
après passé l'analyse de ma situation où
j'ai osé passer le cap
en partageant avec le monde mais écrit
parce que je ne voulais pas dit mais
j'écrivais depuis l'enfance et je
gardais 7 des bouts de papier papous
mais je n'osais pas partager avec les
gens je suis sûr que parmi vous il ya
des personnes qui ont une passion
secrète ou alors un domaine qu'il cache
et que vous n'osez pas vous ne lisez pas
à parler à vos parents vous n'osez pas
en parler à vos amis
parce que on va vous dire peut-être que
vous êtes médecin comme docteur zen et
vous ne pouvez pas être médecin en même
temps faire du théâtre mais pourquoi pas
je suis sûr qu'il ya plusieurs personnes
parmi vous qui ont une double
personnalité entre parenthèses une un
talent caché ou un talent connu qui ne
demande qu'à être révélé qu'est ce qu'il
faut pour révéler son talent il faut
s'écouter
cette mission il faut s'écouter fermer
les yeux
je vous invite à fermer les yeux
sans regarder vos téléphones s'il vous
plaît merci parce que je sais que le
téléphone tout le monde le regarde
fermez les yeux et écoutez vous nous
serons vernis des bruits des bruits de
l'extérieur les bruits de l'extérieur
c'est les autres
sartre disait bien l'enfer c'est les
autres les bruits de l'extérieur c'est
les réseaux sociaux sur lesquels nous
sommes en permanence les bruits de
l'extérieur c'est les emails et les
opinions des autres les bruits de
l'extérieur ce sont les pieds le piège
c'est le piège du paraître nous aimer
banques nous aimons bien paraître
nous aimons bien paraître et nous
pensons que nous sommes jugeait que par
rapport à nos apparences la voiture que
nous conduisons la maison nous habitons
le poste que nous occupons mais nous
sommes plus que ça quand on s'écoute on
se rend compte qu'il ya beaucoup plus
que ça on y lit à un monde en nous il ya
un monde qui a envie de s'exprimer il ya
une petite fois qu'ils nous parlent
il ya la petite voix qui t'ai dit non ne
vais pas là-bas ne fait pas ça parce que
si tu ne fais tout le monde va te
critiquer va te juger et la petite voix
qui t'ai dit fait le soin ce que tu veux
être
réveille toi au monde devient danseur
devient chanteur devient musicien et le
devenir ne t'empêche pas de garder son
emploi
ça n'empêche pas écrit le matin empêché
de continuer à être chef d'entreprise
écrire jusqu'à aujourd'hui pouvoir avoir
publiquement il ya un mois qui s'appelle
évasion virtuel qui était une histoire
que je publiais sur mon blog il ya dix
ans qui aujourd'hui est un roman qui est
vendu depuis plus d'un mois en côte
d'ivoire et dans d'autres pays d'afrique
on s'écoute en quatrième mais on va à la
rencontre de ses démons les démons ce
sont nos peurs ce sont nos incapacités
ce sont nos limites l'intérieur nos
démons ce sont les questions que l'on se
pose et qui nous font peur ce sont nos
imperfections notées mais c'est quand on
se regarde dans le miroir et on se rend
compte qu'on n'est pas si parfait que ça
nous gardons nous des mais c'est quand
on se rend compte que nous ne vivons que
pour les autres pas pour nous mêmes la
peur nous empêchent d'avancer la paire
nous empêche d'être nous mêmes alors
rencontrons le démon faisons face à nos
peurs
regardez nous regardons les en face et
essayons de les affronter
on les embrassons à bras le corps mais
dire mais je les ai embrassé
j'avais peur j'avais peur que le mend
sachent qui je suis à travers mon
écriture
j'avais peur que le monde puisse
comprendre mes émotions comprendre ma
sensibilité en lisant les choses que
j'écrivais je me suis rendu compte que
finalement c'est ce que je suis et que
le regard de l'autre ne diminue en rien
ce que je suis et que le regard de
l'autre n'influence en rien ce que je
peux être
ce fut m'amener à délivrer mon message
quel est mon message
mon message c'est un message de sedan
paramount comme on dit en anglais un
essai de permanence de prise de pouvoir
émotionnel je suis pas dans le féminisme
s'il vous plaît classique ne vous sentez
pas agresser messieurs vous pouvez libre
l'accès mais une femme je me suis rendu
compte que inconsciemment j'écrivais
toutes les femmes et aussi pour les
hommes parce que je pense que la
conversation pour les femmes ne se fait
pas sans les hommes et inconsciemment je
me suis rendu compte que mes textes de
raisonner de plus en plus auprès des
femmes et je me suis retrouvé au nigeria
en gambie en côte d'ivoire en rdc et
dans plusieurs pays à avoir des séances
de discussion avec des femmes
ce que j'appelle des séances de saint
paul je peux dire je ne peux pas dire
autre chose parce que comme je le dis
c'est pas du coaching
parce que ce sont des séances où nous
parlons nous échangeons j'apprends des
cultures des autres femmes jeunes
échangent avec elle et c'est ensemble
que nous prenons des solutions après le
message je suis passé à l'action de
l'action c'est la publication l'action
c'est le partage avec les autres
comment est-ce que vous agissez vous
agissez en apprenant bien sûr je suis
scientifique
c'est vrai j'ai une carrière dans la
communication et dans le commercial mais
j'ai eu à apprendre et à perfectionner
mon écriture à apprendre à écrire un
roman j'écrivais une histoire mais
pourquoi cette histoire puisse devenir
un roman j'ai dû prendre des cours
essayez de savoir comment se structure
un roman j'ai dû pour acheter des livres
main fermée et me former donc l'action
elle passe par un plan par un peu en
formation un plan de stratégie
et vous est-ce que je veux aller je suis
un point ah tu vas arriver à z comment
je fais j'ai eu à rencontrer des
personnes parce que je suis une
capitaliste moi je sais comment on gagne
de l'argent mais je ne sais pas du tout
comment publier un livre donc j'ai pu
avoir des personnes qui m'ont aidée sur
le chemin pour que je puisse publier mon
roman
et ensuite
qui suis je suis devenu mois noirs tels
que vous me voyez aujourd'hui je suis la
personne vrai et être moi qu'est-ce que
ça m'a apporté
je peux dire que être soi même c'est le
début du bonheur oser être soi même
dépasser ses limites
aller au delà des idées des autres c'est
une partie de la vie que nous devons
tous expérimentés être soins c'est
pouvoir avancer un jour se dire j'ai
vécu je vous invite donc à essayer
demain de faire quelque chose que vous
n'avez jamais fait de dire quelque chose
à quelqu'un que vous avez toujours envie
de dire et faites-le essaie de le
publier sur un réseau social partagez le
avec quelqu'un et c'est un petit peu
vous verrez comment vous sentirez vous
sentirez certainement mieux parce que ce
sont prisonniers prisonnier de ses
ambitions prisonnier de ses idées
prisonnier de sa propre personnalité
merci
[Applaudissements]